[Music]
[Music]
this is a farm in horizonte's in
north-east of iran saffron is known as
the most valuable plant in the world and
has been growing in iran from thousands
of years
saffron stems from Iran's history
knowledge and experience aboard saffron
has been conveyed and developed from
generation to generation
since saffron does not need too much
water to grow it stripped iran's clément
[Music]
iran is currently the biggest saffron
producer of the world with production of
360 metric tons of dr saffron per year
and has more than 90 percent share of
the global production follows
representatives said iranian saffron is
under fleet the best in the world
[Music]
[Music]
Safran is used in traditional medicine
for improving the cardiovascular system
and creating joy many effects such as
being anti cancers improving memory
improving sexual potency and many other
medical benefits have been found in
Safra
[Music]
Eman Tara luncheon-table that I was in
hospital insignias diminish more gamma
regna terrae favor mystic muslin loin
Adara diminish more comma y akbar co-op
ahora todas Emma irritable table no
mocha mama no Firebird on the surgery
table is aluminum or hide our mission
[Music]
Oh